مقطعا مصورا عبر حسابها على تيليجرام قالت
انه يوثق استهداف المدفعيه الروسيه مواقع
اوكرانيه في افدي افكا شرقي البلاد تظهر
اللقطات المصوره عبر طائره استطلاعيه لحظه
رصد مواقع تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه
واستهدافها بشكل مباشر حسب الفيديو وقالت
الوكاله ان المدفعيه الروسيه تلقت معلومات
استخباريه من المروحيات لتوقع بالوحده
الاوكرانيه في فخ وتلحق بها الهزيمه
هذا وافاد السلطات الاوكرانيه بمقتل شخصين
واصابه اخرين في تجدد القصف الروسي على
المقاطعه الجنوبيه وقالت السلطات ان الروس
قصفوا اراضي المقاطعه خلال الساعات
الماضيه اكثر من 130 مره بالمدفعيه
الثقيله وبصواريخ جراد والطائرات المسيره
واضافت ان القصف استهدف مركز المدينه
والمناطق المدنيه والبنيه التحتيه يذكر ان
الجيش الاوكراني اصدر قرارا قبل ايام
فيه خرسون مقاطعه مغلقه وقال ان قوته تعمل
على تطهير الشريط الساحلي الشرقي من نهر
دنيبر في المقاطعه التي تسيطر عليه القوات
الروسيه